Тиск - це і є зазіхання на незалежність
На суддю наразі може здійснювати тиск як держава
через свої органи, так і громадськість.
Судова реформа не може завершитися за два роки.
зміни до закону, які зараз пропонують, вочевидь, послаблюють суди
Сьогодні ми говоримо про ініційовані Володимиром Зеленським
зміни до судового законодавства, тиск влади на судову систему
Говоримо ми про це з Валентиною Данішевською, головою Верховного суду України.
Четвертого листопада Володимир Зеленський підписав закон
про внесення змін до деяких законів України
щодо діяльності органів суддівського самоврядування.
Цей закон майже навпіл скорочує склад Верховного суду,
він перезапускає Вищу кваліфікаційну комісію суддів
та призначає перевірку Вищої ради правосуддя за допомогою іноземних експертів.
Але ще до підписання закону Ви в одному з інтерв’ю говорили,
що сподіваєтесь на вето закону Зеленським, адже
цей закон може знищити незалежність судової системи.
Чим він загрожує?
цей закон торкнувся майже усіх сфер суддівського життя.
Він торкнувся і кількісного складу Верховного суду, і кожного судді,
бо запроваджує нові і більш строгі, обтяжливі процедури
дисциплінарного провадження щодо суддів.
Він торкнувся діяльності судових органів, таких як
Вища кваліфікаційна комісія та Вища рада правосуддя.
Закон дуже масштабний, не залишилося жодного судді
чи жодного члена наших суддівських органів, якого б цей закон не зачепив.
Він, як це визнали і пленум Верховного суду,
і Вища рада правосуддя, та й численні міжнародні експерти,
зазіхає на незалежність судової гілки влади.
Які саме положення треба скасувати, щоб система
залишилася на тому ж рівні незалежності, що й зараз?
В 2016-му році були внесені зміни до Конституції і
прийнято нові закони про судоустрій та статус суддів,
які забезпечували досить високий рівень незалежності судової влади.
На рівні норм права, на рівні норм Конституції і законів України.
Своїм завданням я бачу досягнення дійсної незалежності,
тобто щоб ці норми права були наповнені життям, щоб ми це відчували.
Тобто два роки ми над цим працювали. І нині ця незалежність, вочевидь, послаблюється.
Ми відчуваємо втручання, яке не обговорювалося, не погоджувалося судовою гілкою влади.
Законопроект був внесений в перший день роботи Верховної Ради
і буквально через кілька днів вже поставлений на голосування.
Це порушило демократичні основи функціонування всіх гілок влади,
адже не було розглянуто обов'язковий до розгляду
висновок Вищої ради правосуддя до цього законопроекту.
Один з його моментів, який ви також згадували, це рішення
майже удвічі скоротити кількість суддів Верховного суду. А які були пояснення?
Що Верховний суд не повинен розглядати таку велику кількість справ,
але ж ці всі справи вже в нас є, і ми мусимо їх розглядати.
Що Верховний суд начебто не забезпечив єдність судової практики,
але ми вже зробили величезне зрушення в цьому напрямку.
А по-друге, слід розуміти, що єдність судової практики не можна ось так взяти і забезпечити.
Суперечливість практики виникає час від часу.
Наприклад, з прийняттям нових законів, коли ще немає стабільної практики.
Тож завдання Верховного суду забезпечити єдність судової практики – на віки.
Скільки буде існувати Верховний суд, стільки він і буде
займатися тим, щоб забезпечити однакове ставлення до всіх людей, однакову дію закону.
Ви сказали, що нова влада здійнює тиск на судову систему.
Чи розцінюєте ви новий закон як один з чинників такого тиску?
Тиск - це і є зазіхання на незалежність.
Незалежним суддя може бути лише тоді, коли в державі створюються умови для цього.
А по-друге, він повинен не відчувати ані тиску, ані погроз, ані ризиків.
І цей закон створює такі умови, що суддя буде, власне, боятися приймати рішення.
Дуже часто критика на адресу судової системи є виправданою.
Центр протидії корупції,  Автомайдан та фундація Деюре навіть створили
цілий реєстр провалів Вищої ради правосуддя при очищенні судової системи.
те, що n-на кількість громадських організацій так серйозно
привертає увагу до цієї теми, говорить, що вона все ж комусь болить.
Чи справді можна говорити про певний рівень незалежності,
коли є такі проблеми з очищенням судової системи?
На суддю наразі може здійснювати тиск як держава через свої органи, так і громадськість.
А суддя, якщо ми хочемо, щоб він незалежно і неупереджено ухвалював свої рішення,
не повинен відчувати тиску ані з одного, ані з іншого боку.
ому будь-яка демонстрація перед судом чинить тиск на суддю.
Бо якщо людині знадобиться суд, то кожен з нас хоче, щоб на суддю ніхто не
вплинув: ніхто не зателефонував, ніхто не кричав під вікнами, ніхто не телефонував
і не погрожував або звільненням, або дисциплінарним провадженням.
Саме такий суддя потрібен людям, так? А поміж тим, що ми спостерігаємо?
Кожен, хто має доступ до ЗМІ, до приміщень суду, хто може надрукувати свій аналіз
чи показати щось по телебаченню, користається цим.
Ми не можемо допустити, щоб думка якоїсь людини,
якоїсь організації могла так переважати.
Наразі ми спостерігаємо, що думка громадськості і думка влади не збігаються.
То як тоді має діяти суддя? Він має боятися приймати будь-яке рішення,
бо він або владі не догодить, або громадскості не догодить,
або ще хтось схоче звільнити його за те, що він прийняв рішення.
І ми вже стоїмо на порозі того, що для деяких справ ми зовсім
суддів не знайдемо. Вони будуть просто ховатися.
Кому має бути підзвітним суддя, якщо ані громадськість,
ані влада не мають фінального слова у тому, хто правий, а хто винний?
Суддя, як і будь-яка влада, підзвітний суспільству. Але суспільство - різне.
І активні громадяни, які представляють якусь організацію...
Очевидно, їхня думка зовсім необов’язково буде збігатися з думкою інших громадян.
Тож суддя має підкорятися закону, принципу верховенства права.
І головне, що від нього вимагається – що він повинен бути вільним у прийнятті свого рішення.
Через своє власне переконання, через сприйняття закону,
через сприйняття тієї практики, яка напрацьована
і в судовій системі України, і в європейських судах.
От цим має бути наповнений суддя, коли приймає рішення.
Це, мабуть, те, що об’єднує принаймні в публічній площині і команду Зеленського,
і команду Порошенка: і ту, і іншу команду звинувачували у спробі тиснути на судову систему.
Як би Ви оцінили ситуацію при цих двох президентах?
Наскільки відрізняється ситуація принаймні з точки зору тиску на суддів з боку влади?
Я би не хотіла оцінювати президентів, бо я не знаю
як людей ані Порошенка, ані Зеленського.
А про те, що приймається під час їхньої діяльності,
то, як я вже сказала, в 2016 році через прийняття змін до Конституції
і нових законів про судоустрій і статус суддів
судова система отримала формальну незалежність.
Зараз ми це втрачаємо. Я не можу сказати, що хтось з президентів
здійснював якийсь безпосередній тиск або взагалі з цього приводу
спілкувався, скажімо, зі мною чи якось публічно.
Але зміни до закону, які зараз пропонують,
вочевидь послаблюють суди. І Верховний суд, і суди нижчих інстанцій.
Свого часу у травні той самий Порошенко казав, що йому не вистачило
однієї каденції, щоб завершити реформу правосуддя.
Дехто з експертів називає судову реформу його особистим прокляттям,
що вона не вдалася, вона повність провальна.
Я так розумію, що Ви не розділяєте настільки скептичну оцінку,
але чи дійсно можна вважати, що судова реформа виявилася незавершеною,
і якщо виявилась незавершеною, то у чому саме,
чого не вистачило для того, що вона була вдалою?
Судова реформа не може завершитися за два роки.
За два роки вона лише набирає обертів, вибудовуються системи,
які в подальшому дадуть відповідні результати.
Те, що у нас немає стабільності у впровадженні реформ, це величезний мінус.
Кожна влада, яка приходить – чи то був би Порошенко на новий строк,
чи то прийшов Зеленський – всі мають підсилювати досягнення
і докладати зусиль до подолання проблем.
Зараз ми спостерігаємо нівелювання досягнень.
Ми весь час перебуваємо в якомусь новому процесі і повертаємося до старту.
А нам вже треба колись до фінішу, щоб можна було оцінити результати.
Їх не можна оцінити за рік чи два.
Одна з речей, яка стала наслідком цієї судової реформи
це створення Антикорупційного суду, тобто
унікальної для української судової системи інституції.
Багато хто з антикорупційних активістів покладає на цей суд великі надії.
Ви поділяєте, по-перше, цей оптимізм,  і взагалі наскільки
ви вважаєте доцільним створювати окремий
судовий орган для розгляду антикорупційних справ?
Якщо ми вже його створили, ми мусимо зробити так,
щоби він дав позитивні результати.
Між тим хочу зазначити, що антикорупційний суд ну скажімо
подавався суспільству як такий якому довіряють
аж до того, поки він не прийняв перше рішення.
Як тільки він прийняв своє перше рішення,
це одразу було розкритиковано, включаючи і владою.
І вже антикорупційний суд сприймається критично.
Тому що він своїм рішенням то громадській організації не догодив, то прокуратурі не догодив,
то хтось ще інший можливо б по-іншому вирішував би це питання.
чи наважитеся Ви дати якусь оцінку ось цим першим рішенням?
Зрозуміло, що коментувати дії колег складно,
але ось ваші сподівання антикорупційний суд поки що якимось чином задовільняє?
Чи можна сказати, що він дійсно незалежний і його рішення
дійсно відповідають тим судовим практикам, які від нього очікують?
Я задоволена перед усім тим, що судді Антикорупційного суду
почуваються як судді в складі судової системи.
Вони не вважать себе складовою антикорупційних органів.
І доти доки вони будуть поводитися саме як судді, я сподіваюся, що це буде успіх.
Але очікувати від суду, що він буде завжди задовольняти клопотання прокуратури
aбо завжди буде приймати обвинувальні вироки, не варто.
Бо суд на те є суд, що він виправдав невинного і покарав винного.
Дякую вам, що поговорили з нами.
Дякую за увагу до нашої системи.